it does feel as if the region that you
represent has been really devastated by
coronavirus recording the most deaths in
the most recent daily figures hospital
admissions up 50 percent how concerned
are you so Sophie good morning to the
figures don't lie and obviously
yesterday yes or a very big increase in
hospital admissions and actually we do
now and clearly have the second biggest
cluster of infections in the country and
of course that's very concerning
distressing for everybody here
particularly the vulnerable but let me
reassure you picking up in a sense the
last answer as well but hospitals are
managing this admirably and all of our
hospitals I've spoken to most of the
CEOs the hospital trusts in the last few
days are on top of this they have the
capacity and of course come this next
weekend we will have the nightingale
hospital at the NEC opening as well to
support our effort that's interesting
that you say that hospitals have got the
capacity at the minute because of course
we are hearing stories of lack of
protective equipment about question
marks over ventilators are you saying
that the West Midlands has got what it
needs
well the ventilator Point is a very
interesting one actually because we've
just heard that that's managed
nationally and they're literally the
information yesterday that the West
Midlands region received 250 additional
ventilators from that national supply so
actually I have confidence that it was
looked at the decision to allocate was
put to here because we do have this
rapidly increasing position at the
moment so yes we have that capacity that
we need and of course the whole thinking
has been that the nightingale hospital
would come on stream when that capacity
gets challenged where there it will be
exactly at the right point remains to be
seen but the planning is absolutely or
that to come on stream next weekend
which should be exactly the right timing
now of course you're all conservative
mayor at the West Midlands but you are
certainly an independent minded one
affair previously Spears with you
anything to go by and what's your take
on how the government's handled the
crisis
my tape would be that they have been
very decisive particularly in the
economic area that we might explore and
my take is also that their determination
to impose the lockdown has been United
actually let's not be naive there have
been some challenges the challenges over
testing the challenge is over PPA but
we've heard from Mac Hancock an absolute
determination to deal with both of them
and again just on another piece of
regional evidence tomorrow we open our
testing driver and testing facility here
at the edge boosting cricket ground so
again there's evidence that what he's
said by Matt actually follows through on
to the ground let's talk about economics
now shall we and we've all seen those
shut up hi streets no one's under any
illusions about the economic hit that
it's gonna happen you were the boss John
Lewis during the last major economic
crisis 2008 do you think this is going
to be worse this is definitely different
there's the short that the fall-off is
much much more acute even than what
happened last time and the whole
question is how quickly can we get back
to a rebound last time it was deep and
prolonged for underlying weaknesses in
the economy before literally we called
it the credit crunch that's what it was
that's what went on this time if we get
this right hopefully we will be able to
bounce back much more quickly because
the underlying strength of the economy
was better as we went into it and that's
why what the Chancellor has done is
taken steps to what you might call
hibernate some parts of the economy so
they will be able to come back and it's
all about how quickly that happens and
that's why even when we talk about
economics we're swinging back to how
much the population observed the
guidelines and get through this together
I think it's interesting you say that
the Chancellor's trying to hibernate the
economy almost like put it in a deep
freeze until this is over but of course
for his policies to work you need
businesses to not lay off staff you also
need banks to lend money to firms are
you worried that either those two things
might not happen so I think the
furloughing
ie the government paying or staff who
would otherwise probably be made
redundant everything I hear about that
is that that's working pretty well we
had a regional economics conference on
the unions big businesses all said
that's working well but that looks like
a well-intentioned policy do you again
very honest with you there are concerns
that as yet the lending through banks is
not coming through as fast as it needs
to
again I've spent of all the leaders the
banks in the West Midlands they are
determined to do this they understand
it's their responsibility but as yet
money's not coming quite as quickly as
anybody would wish one other thing where
money is coming though is obviously the
rebates on business rates and again just
in the West Midlands our local councils
have now got over half a billion pounds
from government to allocate and that
will make a difference coming through
quickly at some point in the future
people will start to weigh out the
economic impact of the lockdown how long
do you think the economy could cope with
the kind of measures that we're seeing
in a minute well it's it's damaging
isn't it everyone can see that but the
whole point is trying to protect good
businesses but my overview on this if
you're taking the sort of question about
economy versus health is at the moment
you've got to fall down decisively on
the side of restoring public health and
that means we have got to observe the
guidelines particularly as everyone said
on a sunny day like this so I am
decisively in the view that says do that
that will restore the public health and
that is the best way of healing the
economy as well